i have proposed on this channel numerous
times that we need to re-examine our
definitions of fitness
too many people will focus on only one
or two aspects of fitness when training
this comes from a lack of knowledge a
desire to be the best in a specific
domain
or a tribalism that keeps them wet to a
single system
but simply being able to squat and
deadlift huge amounts of weight is not
fitness
nor is it the be-all and end-all of leg
strength how about single leg strength
how about rotation after a certain point
adding more and more weight
causes more issues in other aspects of
your fitness just as there is more to
strength than squatting
strength itself is not the ultimate
expression of fitness and performance
many others equate fitness to
cardiovascular endurance
fit to them means being able to run long
distances without throwing up
they lose mass and size they lose the
ability to move explosively
and they miss out on opportunities to
explore the full range of motion their
bodies are capable of
again i want to reiterate here that this
makes sense if you're an endurance
athlete
if that's your career but for the rest
of us focusing on just
one single area of fitness like this
just doesn't make sense
you might laugh at the person who learns
to juggle to supplement their fitness
training
when will they ever need that kind of
hand-eye coordination well they won't
until they do and they're no less likely
to need that skill than they are to be
able to squat 250 kilograms
what about quick decision making and
general cognitive performance
the athlete who wins a contest is rarely
the one who is strongest or fastest
or most endurant more important is how
they are able to apply those traits on
the day
by remaining focused motivated and calm
how about bringing all of that together
into one beautiful ensemble a symphony
of strength agility quickness
decision-making and explosive power
it's that kind of beautiful
communication with the environment that
wins fights
stuns crowds and even saves lives
when you can react quickly think
strategically dodge gracefully and
strike with power and precision
when you can do all that repeatedly with
no sign of fatigue that is when you're
performing at your best
that's the kind of total body and mind
fitness that can really impact your life
in a positive way
imagine being just a bit stronger a bit
more energetic
a bit sharper all at the same time so
that's the objective
the next question is what are these
different aspects that we need to train
how do we define them
i've compiled a list of what i believe
to be the pillars of fitness and
performance
this is by no means a comprehensive list
but rather just a starting point
and hopefully the start of a
conversation these are the basics that i
think everyone should consider training
strength strength is the ability to
exert force on the environment
this could be to move an object to move
yourself to break an object apart
or to prevent movement strength can
further be broken down into subtypes
max strength is the peak output you're
capable of exerting
often measured by your one rep maxes
explosiveness is the amount of strength
you can exert quickly
also known as rate of force production
explosiveness makes for powerful punches
and explosive vertical jumps to be
useful strength should be
accessible on any vector it's not just
enough to be strong in a constrained
movement pattern like the squat or the
deadlift
rather you should be strong when pushing
horizontally from an upright stance
strong in the transverse plane and
strong in unbalanced unilateral
movements
this is how the real world demands us to
be strong whether loading a boot moving
furniture or wrestling an opponent
strength should not just be muscular but
should bring with it denser bones
tougher connective tissue and a powerful
grip
speed speed is the ability to move
quickly from one point to another
this can be further broken down into
movement speed which includes
acceleration
deceleration lateral speed and linear
speed as well as
direction changes quickness or limb
speed and reflexes
speed is a combination of rate of force
production explosiveness
along with efficient movement and neural
drive the goal here is to be able to run
quickly when you need to
which could genuinely save your life but
this doesn't just mean running in a
straight line
but also being able to weave and change
direction you should be fast in a
variety of environments too
whether swimming or running uphill or
across uneven terrain
and that quickness should extend to
smaller movements whether throwing a
punch catching a ball or ducking
endurance endurance represents your
ability to continue to express strength
and speed for long duration
in a real world setting it's rare that
you're ever required to perform a single
feat of incredible strength
far more often you're required to exert
that strength for a significant duration
carrying heavy objects long distances is
more useful than lifting extremely heavy
objects a single time
aerobic endurance is the ability to run
walk or roll long distances at
sub-maximal exertion
this is the low-intensity steady-state
cardio you experience on a 10k run
this is linked to your anaerobic
threshold which is the top speed that
you're capable of maintaining
before being forced to switch to the
next energy system
anaerobic endurance this is the ability
to move at top speed for an extended
period of time
this is best trained with sprints and
high intensity interval training
strength endurance this is the ability
to exert strength for long periods of
time
also called work capacity endurance
adaptations are both systemic and
peripheral
you can have greater endurance in
specific limbs and movements than in
others
thus a ready for anything approach to
endurance should cover multiple
different movement patterns
agility agility is a combination of
strength
speed and mobility but combined with
grace born from proprioception
balance and posture this allows us to
leap high into the air balance along
thin beams and contort our bodies in
mid-air
so we must also train for that balance
that fine motor control and that
coordination
we can do this with more ambitious
calisthenics gymnastic strength training
yoga and countless other protocols
mobility
is the ability to move through a full
range of motion with ease and control
mobility should not be confused with
flexibility whereas flexibility refers
to your ability to force yourself into
position
using external resistance mobility means
getting into those positions
using your own strength mobility and
agility matter in everyday life because
it prevents injury
giving us control and end ranges of
motion allowing us to save a bad landing
or to right ourselves when we start to
fall
and simply by gaining more range of
motion and control in these positions
you'll be able to reduce tightness and
discomfort
cognitive function few people realize
that they can train their brain just as
they can train their body
their habits and career shape brain
regions and the connections between them
via neuroplasticity even fewer people
make this training part of their routine
but training the mind is what would
ultimately lead to the most tangible
rewards for most of us
being more focused better at creative
problem-solving and more compelling as
an orator
would help you excel in your personal
and professional life and even in sports
like i said the athlete who comes out on
top is very often the one who's able to
tap
into their strength speed and power
under pressure the one who can react
quickly and effectively
here are just some of the aspects of
cognitive function that can be trained
focus determination and mental toughness
problem solving and creativity
neural processing fluid intelligence
emotional intelligence working memory
so that's just a starting point just the
tip of the iceberg in terms of what you
can train
we can get far more granular and look at
things like straight arm strength or
even vision but what about the
interference effect
while this is a real concern to a point
the truth is that it's mainly a concern
at the highest level at any one of these
different areas
most people can afford to get a little
stronger and a little faster
a little more agile and a whole lot more
focused and at this level we see that
each of those components of fitness
support and improve the others
agility is enhanced by explosive
strength strength is enhanced by
endurance
emotional intelligence is closely
related to physical intelligence
and that helps us to better manage our
own physiology
the question for those that want to
perform optimally across the board is
where that perfect balance lies
and this is going to be different for
each of us what formula could we devise
to measure total cross-functional
performance
could we create a real-life power level
if you like the idea of training for
much more than just strengths or weight
loss
then you'll probably enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training
i'll put a link to that in description
down below and there's a discount on
right now whilst we're all in lockdown
that goes into a lot of depth on how to
train different aspects of your
performance
both mind and body and then provides a
training program at the end to bring it
all together it's suitable for all
levels and you don't need any
equipment as a whole separate version
for people who don't have access to
weights and dumbbells and ropes to climb
whatever the case thanks a ton for
watching this one subscribe if you want
to see more and i'll see you next time
thanks a ton for watching and bye for
now
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share it around
i'd love to know in the comments down
below which areas of fitness you think i
might have missed out on and what you've
been training yourself
oh yeah we made it to 200 000
subscribers which is just
insane and so awesome another 50 000 and
i'll be a quarter of the way to a
million which
is mind-boggling so just wanted to say a
massive thank you
to everyone who supports the channel who
watches your comments who likes
i'm humbled by it and i can't thank you
enough and i appreciate every single one
of you i'm sorry if i
ever take a while to get back to a
comment or miss one or an email
unfortunately there's just far too much
to answer these days which is not a
complaint it's fantastic but i just want
to say
i read as much as i can and i really
appreciate all of it
you guys rock so yeah thank you
and see you next time bye for now